[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مع هذا الهيكل الشبيه بالفضاء ،
تم تعيين جناح الاستدامة ليكون
محورًا رئيسيًا لمعرض إكسبو 2020.
عند عرض 130 مترًا ، يُطلق على هذه المظلة الضخمة للسقف
اسم
terra بمعنى كوكب الأرض وكلها
تتعلق بمستقبل  العالم من حولنا
[موسيقى
] تم تجهيز السقف وأشجار الطاقة المحيطة
بأكثر من ألف
لوح شمسي
توفر بعض الطاقة
اللازمة لاستضافة هذا الحدث الضخم
، نحاول عرض كيف
يمكن للبشرية بناء
المباني التي تعيش في وئام
مع البيئة من حولهم
الذين تمكنوا من الاستيلاء على الموارد
حول ما إذا كانت الشمس
أو حتى معرض المياه 2020 قد تأخر
لمدة عام بسبب الوباء ،
هذا الجناح هو الأول من نوعه
والمقيمين المحظوظين
والزائرين
يحصلون على لمحة داخل هذا
الهيكل الضخم
هنا يتم إحضارهم إلى تجارب غامرة وتفاعلية
في عالم مليء بالغابات والمحيطات
وتأثير الاستهلاك المفرط
بهدف مساعدة v  يتفهم المراقبون
بشكل خاص الأطفال
تأثيرهم على
البيئة من
خلال تلك التجارب الغامرة والتفاعلية ، فهذه
هي الطريقة التي يمكننا بها التواصل مع
الأشخاص ، وهذه هي الطريقة التي يمكننا بها
بدء المحادثات المهمة بدلاً
من مجرد تقديم المعلومات
، ومن المتوقع أن يحضر ملايين الزوار
الحدث من أكتوبر هذا
إلى  نهاية مارس في العام المقبل
بعد المعرض ، سيستمر الجناح في
إلهام الأجيال القادمة
وسيكون بمثابة مثال على
التصميم المستدام مع المبنى ليصبح
مركزًا علميًا
في المنطقة 2020 مجتمعًا
جديدًا سيتطور من موقع المعرض
منذ أن شرعنا في  التخطيط لهذا
الجناح وضعنا في الاعتبار المستقبل
وصممناه ليكون مركزًا
للأطفال والعلوم التي ستبقى
بعد المعرض ، وستستمر في
إلهام جيل المستقبل حول
الإجراءات التي يمكنهم اتخاذها
حول البيئة
[موسيقى]
تحيط بها  الهياكل المستدامة الأخرى
والعروض المثيرة للتفكير
لزوار تارا حتى ر  أعطي العاشر من
أبريل لمحة
عما سيأتي خلال إكسبو 2020
ومن خلال جناح الاستدامة
تخيل ما يمكن
أن يبدو عليه كوكبنا ويحتاج إليه في المستقبل.